Mousa and fateh were each asked to
factor the quadratic expression 16x
squared minus 64
their responses are shown below so Moosa
factored it this way
Fatou factored it this way which student
wrote an expression that is equivalent
to 16 x squared minus 64 so I encourage
you to pause the video and figure that
out which student wrote an expression
that is equivalent to our original one
16x squared minus 64 well let's work
through it together so let's see if
first we can factor this out somehow to
get what Moussa got and it looks like
Moussa first factored out a 16 and then
he was left with a difference of squares
so let's see if we can do that so we can
write our original expression 16x
squared minus 64 we can write that as 16
times x squared minus 16 times 4 now
when you write it like that it's very
clear that you can factor out a 16 so
this is going to be equal to a 16 times
what you have left over is x squared
minus 4 and then x squared minus 4
that's the that's a difference of
squares right over there so we can that
part we can factorize so we have our
original 16 and then and then this part
right over here we can write as X plus 2
times X minus 2 X plus 2 times X minus 2
if what I just did in this last step
going from x squared minus 4 2 X plus 2
times X minus 2 doesn't make any sense I
encourage you to watch some of the
introductory videos on factoring a
difference of squares
but the basic idea I have a form here of
a squared minus B squared so it's going
to have the form of a plus B times a
minus B in this case it's x squared
minus 2 squared so it's going to be X
plus 2 times X minus 2 so that's exactly
what Moussa got so this one so Moussa
did get an expression that is equivalent
to 16 x squared minus 64 now let's think
about fatou so fatou didn't factor out a
16 from the get-go it looks like he just
immediately recognized that what we our
original expression is itself a
difference
squares even if we don't factor out a 16
and so let's rewrite it so our original
expression we could write as so we could
write it instead of writing let me just
write like this this is our original
expression 16x squared minus 64 that's
the same thing as 16x squared is the
same thing as 4x the whole thing squared
and then minus 8 squared so when you
write it like this it's clear that this
is a difference of squares so this is
going to be 4x plus 8 times 4x minus 8
4x plus 8 times 4x minus 8 once again if
this last step that I did doesn't make a
lot of sense I encourage you to watch
the video on factoring difference of
squares we be able go a lot more into
the intuition of it but when you see it
this way you realize that fought 2 also
got an expression that is equivalent to
16 x squared minus 64 so they both did